oh me too
in my head i'm like play it cool play it
cool but i can't i love you so much
thank you i i ha i had the
amazing pleasure of meeting you in
person
what was it haley like a almost a decade
ago
i had to have been it had to have been
but i have to say i remember it
like it was yesterday me too
and it was interesting because putting
this
piece together for the show i've come to
an interesting realization so um
when you came in um you saw
like the picture frames on the wall
will you tell me about that yeah so
i where i was sitting i was sitting
across from you you were sitting behind
your desk and i believe that wall was
i want to say behind where i was sitting
regardless of where it was i
didn't know whether to stare at you or
the wall because i was equally as
fascinated by both
um and my mom i remember my mom was with
me at the meeting and it was i had a
moment of like mom you gotta see
this wall this is incredible and and you
were so kind as to invite her into your
uh office there and my mom got inspired
uh
by that wall because a couple years
later when i had a couple covers of my
own
uh she framed them and put them up on my
wall uh
and it was a it was a weird thing for me
at first but i realized like what an
incredible thing to actually be able to
look at that and and see what you've
accomplished um
in such a way so thank you for that uh
my mom thanks you too
do we did we show a picture of the wall
i was staring at you okay perfect
um take a look at this so actually that
office
was chris miller who's producing the
show we've been partners for
over 20 years um and
that was his office and when he first
put those
framed like covers up i was mortified
because i felt really shy and
embarrassed
and what i realized through what your
mom did
is that we need someone
to shout out our accomplishments because
we won't do it for ourselves usually
totally totally and i will say i was
absolutely mortified myself and it was
like
a little i was like what do i do when
people come into my my room or like my
little closet even there's like pictures
of myself i was just very bizarre
but um it took me a minute to realize
that it actually is a really
wonderful thing and something i would
never do myself so you're right
it's true you need some like that's what
family does
found or blood you know they celebrate
you in a way that we
can't celebrate ourselves because we
want to be like humble and about the
work and
you know it just it you helped me
realize how
important that is to enjoy someone
else's
uh celebration of you so thank you for
that realization
um you and your mom are really close
and she just supported your decision
to like become an actor when you were
young and
i got to do that without question and
i'm so relieved because i love
the life i've gotten to live and i
wouldn't have it any other way what was
that like
that journey with your mom growing up
her supporting you
oh my gosh i i mean it's very safe to
say i would not be aware
i am without my mom and the countless
hours she spent researching uh
how to get me into the right place at
the right time
and making sure that i was prepared but
i mean it felt like my mom and i lived
out of her car for my
whole childhood just driving to
auditions and one after the other
sometimes
multiple in a day um and it was just a
you know a rocky road i mean at times it
just was like
sometimes it was obviously as you know
great and wonderful and you receive good
news and other times you don't and
more times you you don't uh at least for
a while for me anyway that was the case
um but she never gave up on me and she
knew that it was something i wanted and
that's what kept her
going um and through that she just was
unbelievably
encouraging and and loving and
supportive
uh and again wouldn't be where i was
without her
it's so rare that like a parent
encourages and realizes
someone young's dreams it's like
you know it's not always the case and
it's
it's pretty wonderful when it is and
it's true you do
you learn young to deal with rejection
which is like
kind of becomes a strength but my mom
would always take me
for a filleto fish at mcdonald's and i
do
still associate like comfort with creamy
carbs and i love it
did you and your mom ever have a ritual
when it didn't go
the way you wanted it to you know
food was definitely involved i mean so
we um
my parents are are still in the house
that i grew up in and it's um
quite you know i mean it's a bit of a
ways from
town uh where all auditions were held
and so there were you know so many
restaurants out
in town that we you know would never eat
at and we definitely would stop at like
a diner was like the go-to
you know pancakes were definitely a
go-to no matter what time it was
um but yeah i mean sometimes sometimes
it was just getting in the car and going
home
you know i i
i wonder you know do you have any advice
because rejection really is something
that you're going to have to deal with
throughout your life every
human is going to go on a journey where
every single thing is not going to go
their way
or work out or that dream doesn't seem
realized do you have any advice you have
such a megaphone
to so many people you know do you have
any wisdom i would say
i am i'm a huge believer and everything
happens for a reason
and sometimes i mean i tell myself that
too many times a day and so it's easier
said than you know
felt or understood because oftentimes
we're looking for that reason why
um but i believe that there is
a place for everyone in this world and
um you know
timing is everything that's something i
i had to learn you know i think it's
very easy to feel like
you did i did something wrong or i
wasn't you know uh i wasn't as prepared
as i should have been but i have to know
that in that moment i trust that i did
everything i could and maybe the timing
just wasn't right
haley i built a hand-drawn neon sign
in my entryway that says timing is
everything
i have amazing skills everywhere it's so
true and it takes a long time to
believe and trust in that but it is true
and all these things are building blocks
they are not going by the wayside they
are building blocks for something else
at another time and it is all worthwhile
i have chills head to toe i'm so glad
that you said that
that feels like it takes a lifetime to
understand or get to know
you are so wise
you